[Music]
hey everybody Welcome to our hallway
chat I haven't come up with a final name
for this but this is our experiment to
see if you all like these um but my
thought process here is you know how
some people say their favorite part of
conferences are those conversations they
get to have in the hallway when you get
to talk with someone about something you
just learned or how it applied to you or
maybe something you wish a presentation
covered so in one of our data science
Hangouts in early November somebody had
asked are you ever asked to estimate the
ROI return on investment from an
analytics project before the business is
willing to invest in
anything and a shout out to Nick who
asked that I'm not sure if Nick's
actually here on the call
now um but how do you approach that and
so there was a lot of conversation about
this in the chat and people wanting to
talk more about it so here we are I
posted on LinkedIn to see who'd be open
to sharing their process for this and
would love to introduce two leaders
joining us
today they'll both share their thoughts
to kick off the conversation but this is
a group discussion about all things Roi
to share ideas and our own experiences
to help each other like the data science
Hangouts it's totally okay to just
listen in here but if you have follow-up
questions on the topic or want to
provide your own perspective on what's
worked or hasn't worked there's a few
ways you can contribute so you can raise
your hand here on
zoom and just to tell people how if
you're not familiar with that in the bar
below there's a rea actions button and
from there you can raise your hand you
could put questions in the zoom chat and
feel free to just put a star next to it
if it's something you want me to read
out loud instead maybe you're in a
coffee shop or something and then lastly
we have a slido link which I will share
here in the
chat in just a
second um but you can ask questions
anonymously there as well
and thank you to somebody who just said
I need to switch my background because
it needs to mirror the the posit logo
it's showing okay on my side I put a
virtual background because I'm at my
parents house and was hiding everything
behind me did that last minute um but
just to let everybody know like the data
science Hangouts this session will be
recorded So if you want to go back and
listen again uh I'll be sure to share
that to the posit YouTube but before
jumping in just a reminder we're all
dedicated to making our community events
a welcoming environment for everybody we
love hearing from everybody no matter
your years of experience the languages
that you work in titles or
industry well with all that thank you so
much for spending time with us today I'd
love to introduce both Joe Powers
principal data scientist at Inuit and
Derek BN director of advanced analytics
at St Michael's Hospital do you both
want to maybe kick things off by just
sharing a little bit with us about each
of your roles and kind of say hello
before we dive into Roi sure Dereck you
want to lead off sure thanks uh so I'm
Derek director of Advance analytics um
uh in a unit at St Michael's Hospital in
Toronto um our unit is data science and
Advance analytics we are an Applied
Healthcare unit uh so we put um stats
MLA aai tools into production uh for
mostly clinical use but there are quite
a few operational or like Staffing
Solutions that we we put into place um
we're not research it's all about
getting things actually done and into
the hands of users um overall our group
is about 30 people uh we technically
work across uh three hospitals um St
Michael St Joseph's and Providence all
in Toronto as part of the Unity Health
Network uh we are mostly in our house uh
we
have maybe 70% of our Solutions R and
then we've got a variety of things in
Python including some new stuff we've
recently launched um with a little bit
of stuff in pretty much any any sort of
analytics Ai and ml domain so Imaging
clinical prediction patient flow
forecasting you name it we probably do a
little bit of it awesome Joe you want to
go next yeah sure um so yeah Joe Powers
I work into it um you're probably
familiar with um like some of our
Flagship products like QuickBooks Turbo
Tax chimp um and yeah so I lead
experimentation which is a huge amount
of Roi um involved in it largely
around investigating new methods for how
we could run faster and more accurate AB
tests for product and marketing
decisions and so you know when you move
a whole company um you know like how
their you're shifting their
decision-making process to a new
statistical method people want to know
like what's why is the juice going to be
worth the squeeze you know on this and
so um yeah when Rachel brought this
topic up I was I was happy to join in
because it's been I feel like this is
one of those hidden curricula topics
that like it's Central to doing your job
as a data scientist but absolutely no
one teaches this so uh you
know good for you for being here
today so I was thinking we kind of jump
in and get started with sharing a little
bit about how you both have approached
this and then people can jump in with
questions and thoughts too um I know you
both have very different approaches to
this too and it's really cool to see the
difference across Industries as well um
I don't know who wants to get started
but I was thinking maybe kind of giving
us a Baseline and sharing a little bit
about about what you
do Derek do you want to
maybe start with explaining how the
process your teams roll out sure yeah um
and in some ways maybe this will feel
really specific but um it's because
we're in healthcare in a hospital uh but
I think a lot of this is pretty
generalizable so and I'll share a
document or part of a document with us
in a moment so when um a project comes
our way uh it usually comes from uh
someone on the ground so physician or
someone in HR or say a clinical manager
in some some way they have a problem
they know data can solve it they work
with a few of us in the team uh
primarily the directors on uh and and
the product managers on filling out and
detailing a project intake form and one
of the most critical parts of the
project intake form which I will Rachel
am I able to
share yes I will just make you a co-host
so that you're able to and I got rid of
my posit logo which was backwards and
the background Andy boardroom here for
this Roi conversation
awesome um a second I'll make you
co-host there you go awesome thank you
so uh I'll do this real fast you can
take away my co-host abilities in a
moment you can keep them I just didn't
want everybody to be able to screen
share so um as part of that project
intake there's a key section here called
evaluation metrics and right off the bat
you should you should have a good idea
of whether you're trying to address
mortality admission length of stay
Financial issues or human effort
generally across um the types of
problems you want to solve in the
hospital there's another box other which
is usually an indicator of like we
probably aren't going to take this on or
it's hard to define or hard to measure
um but a lot of these are generally
easier to track or measure and assess
the impact and from there we work with
our uh collaborators on how to define
the primary metric uh so are you trying
to do something to reduce say length of
stay then we are going to look at how to
do that as well as tracking the um
actual length of stay uh pre- and post
uh deployment and um when we do this we
have discussions early on about what the
expected level of change is um so if you
think you can bring length of stay down
for say all patients in a certain unit
by um uh let's say 30 minutes in like an
ICU or something so you bring the
overall down quite a bit we'll get this
uh written down here and that's how we
proceed and measure and assess things um
uh when it's after the fact uh I'll stop
sharing now but we have a fairly deep
and detailed discussions at this intake
stage about what the metrics are how
we're going to measure it how we're
going to track it and what the um level
of change is is expected to be um and a
lot of the expectation will come from
knowing the hospital or the system uh in
general knowing types of changes that do
exist in other sites where you can point
to literature or something else
somewhere else and say look they saw a
10% reduction so we would expect uh
about the same so a lot of this is based
off of targeting something identify a
key uh Healthcare economics metric and
let's work out how much we think we're
going to actually make a
difference if things aren't um say a
huge benefit or if they fall kind of in
that other box this is where we say like
maybe we're not going to take this on or
we have to dig really deep into the
types of things that might yield value
uh overall for either the unit the
hospital the system like the whole
network of ours um before considering
taking it on so we we get pretty deep
into this on on how we actually um
assess and decide what to do before we
fully commit um as as part of this where
we NE we won't necessarily like uh
Rachel so I guess to your points like
before any commitment there is some
commitment we have um uh or that we'll
get into so so if people come to us and
they're like yeah I think we can get
this measure here here here and we want
to get a a baseline we'll absolutely
work with anyone to establish what those
baselines are uh so that part comes with
the project intake it's just the um
deciding to move into the uh full
development of something is really where
we need to see what that Baseline is and
really dig into what these improvements
are going to be and I'm sorry if you
said this already but how long have you
had that process in place with the
intake form um quite a while uh the
intake form here has been revised as
recently as a little over a year ago um
but those metrics uh have been in place
pretty much since um since the start of
this group which predates me um so
always trying to Target uh big
Healthcare economics type metrics well I
I was just asking in the chat I was
curious for people listening in if you
have something for similar to that like
a project intake form um and if so what
some of those evaluation metrics might
be for
you um as a maybe a good reminder I
should have set upfront but I love to
see everybody talking in the chat and
during these sessions too if you've been
to a data science hangout before you
might see like a lot of resources get
shared in the chat so feel free to to
use that during the session
too Joe do you want to share a little
bit um I think I just like kind of echo
some key things that dererk said around
like identifying you know those key
metrics uh a lot of people talk about
stakeholders I tend to think about
Gatekeepers you know you have lots of
stakeholders but really thinking now
about which ones are The Gatekeepers
that are going to block or allow uh your
project to roll out so like what are the
metrics that they really care about and
yeah establishing Baseline there's you
know there's very likely a dashboard
that those leaders are regularly
referring to you know that you know you
can anchor to as a shared reality um and
then what is a reasonable uh lift that
you could expect um that could be based
on you know literature review it could
be based on qualitative testing you know
if you looked at 20 users in ux settings
you said oh our invoice completion rate
went from 20% to 90% with the new um you
know invoice flow uh that is actually a
great Anchor Point that you could now
start thinking about like okay like
that's in an idealized setting but when
it moves into the product like you know
what's reasonable to expect um so a lot
of times you're just dealing with the
best data or you know best uh
information you can get your hands on
and that can run the gamut from you know
maybe it was captured in your data Lake
to you know running a few surveys or
doing some some qualitative sessions but
you know any any information is better
than none um so any yeah you know key
metrics baselines reasonable lift
and then like actually that's where for
me it becomes a data simulation task
after that and and I'll I'm happy to
share a little bit because like I said
nobody ever like taught me how to do
this but it's just become like my you
know go-to for the workflow um so you
know I'm in our studio right now and you
know loaded the Tidy Burse and so you
can imagine yeah my Baseline is this
rate a so maybe I have a 50% uh rate
maybe this is like you know a conversion
rate or you know a click rate whatever
is that key metric for your
Gatekeepers and now maybe I'm just going
to explore some like reasonable lift
like maybe I think I could lift this a
tenth of a percent with some new program
okay I've got you know 100,000 customers
and I'm gonna run 4,000
simulations so uh yeah I can execute
this now in in this cell so I'm using
the binomial distribution if you're not
familiar or you're not comfortable using
these likelihood um functions uh I I
think this is something just really
worth leaning into um
like a lot of abstract statistics become
really concrete and intuitive once you
get comfortable simulating data with
Life Food functions U so all I'm doing
here is I'm running 4,000 simulations uh
with 100,000 trials and I can set the
probability of success on each
trial and this is going to Output like a
tally of events but then once I divide
that by the population I'll always get a
rate so maybe this outputs you know uh
50,000 events but when that divides by
100,000 now I get a 50% rate okay
so um you know I could actually just
give you a Peak at like you
[Music]
know so yeah I get for my first
simulation I have like
50.1% you know the second one 50. too um
I hope this is getting like clear I
tried to keep this minimal would
you now would you be able to describe
kind of like what's a a project that you
might be working on where you would be
doing this
so you know you could think of this is
really very close to the idea of a power
analysis like you know if you were
introducing this 0.1% Improvement you
know you could start asking questions
like How likely are we to detect it um
and so
you know even in this case like if I
just look at how often are my you know B
simulations bigger than my a simulations
that's not saying it's statistically
significant it's just saying bigger at
all uh it's you know this small of the
change in a you know 100,000 users you
know 68% of the time uh you would it
would be
larger um you could explore like the
range of differences that you might
observe you know uh like a you know an
inter like a 95% interval of those
potential
differences the very concrete examples
that I could give are like when I'm
exploring a new AB testing
method uh what I'm going to do is I'm
going to simulate the test data from
100,000 AB tests and then I can start
asking very practical questions from
those simulated data like how often did
I detect you know the superior uh
treatment condition how long did it take
to detect the superior treatment
condition how many additional
conversions did we yield because we
detected the better experience earlier
and rolled it out uh you know to 100%
earlier in the
season those are the kind of return on
investment questions that I can explore
using very basic data simulation that
you know my Gatekeepers my stakeholders
like really care about uh they want to
know before they Greenlight um you know
using a new statistical method in
they're going to want to know does this
detect benefit more often and faster
does it detect harm more often and
faster um and you know that's just all
this is all just you know that initial
return on investment research they're
going to want to know the same thing on
the tail end of the project about like
how well this lived up uh to um you know
to your projections but I I just wanted
to show this as like you know using
these likelihood functions that you know
you have available in you know in numai
you have available in basar um but
they're they're very powerful and
they're very persuasive uh when you're
trying to do like Roi sizing for a new
project oh that's great thank
you and thinking about that like the ROI
that you showed there how do you
translate that into communication with
the business stakeholders is it through
like a business case
document
um through all means possible so um
it's you know again you know as I
mentioned Gatekeepers earlier like
thinking about who's approval who's
buying you need for a project to get
green lit um that person is gonna have a
lot of people demanding their attention
they've got a lot of fires to put out
like how are you going to get your idea
in front of them so that it
sticks um you know you give a 20-minute
presentation uh you know 20 minutes
later they're probably only going to if
you if you succeed it they're only going
to remember one or two things from that
presentation and so you know the like
Clarity of your communication and we had
a former CEO who loved the expression uh
repetition doesn't Sully the prayer you
know just repeat repeat repeat and just
keep kind of driving home that Central
message that appeals to that like if
they have an urgent problem and you're
offering the solution if you're doing it
clearly you're not going to have to
offer it that many times um but be ready
to deliver um and so anyhow but but yeah
through through communication it's like
you know start sending word out in slack
Channel offer uh you know I guess more
peer supportive trainings through you
know Zoom meetings and live meetings get
your peers on board you know try to get
work through your manager to get um you
know FaceTime in you know there's
usually recurring executive
presentations uh where you can like get
in front of your leaders uh to pitch um
you know your potential Solutions and if
you're coming in there not only with you
know the performance of your solution
but the return on investment in a metric
they care about and recognize like this
is just all stuff that like greases the
skids to make sure that you know your
project gets a mandate and goes into
practice um and like we said earlier
just be ready on the tail end to verify
that you delivered what you promised
because uh that's that really kind of
like puts a bow on it and you know and
really like cements the relationship
that you know in the future it's just
going to be that much easier for you to
to get that FaceTime get the approval to
put your projects into
production definitely I see um George
you asked a question in the chat a bit
earlier do you want to jump in
here okay yeah sorry I'm battling a cold
my voice is pretty
terel um yeah I was wondering how you
would estimate or measure your own time
investment because I think the other
half of this equation is is
understanding how much effort it will
take for you you to do that and also
like how accurate those estimates
are I have only seen that uh accurately
accurately measured with survey data
like calendar dat I've tried to use
calendar data for these kind of projects
it is meaningless like you know the
Loyalty of people to their calendars the
accuracy the coding just don't even try
it would be my advice um but just you
know asking like a good survey question
about like you know uh in the past week
like asking you know surveying analysts
for instance or surveying the the key
people like in the past week how much
time did you spend on like these parts
of your work um is that a typical week
but usually it helps to like anchor like
anchoring surveys to a specific time
period can really improve the accuracy
of responses but but but honestly just
survey data is the only thing for for
your to answer your question that I
think that's the best signal it's not
great but it's I think it's the best you
can do
Derek do you want to add anything there
uh yeah so estimating ahead of time uh
we don't like that's just it's really
hard to make a guess especially when a
lot of stuff we do is um pretty variable
and unknown especially in the early
start like parts of the projects um
measuring later we're probably a little
bit better about once we're like really
in the weeds and this would come a lot
from our product managers and the way
we've set up like our Sprint Cycles um
got a pretty good track of or at least
within good like small windows we have a
pretty good sense of what we're doing
and how much effort we're putting into
the respective projects um but this is
definitely not something
we I would say estimate very far in
advance so like at the the ROI project
intake stage more so like in the project
is this going to take you a week two
weeks um One Day stuff like that but um
I think where maybe that
question if I would make a guess George
like uh is this about like tradeoff like
how many person hours is it really going
to take is it going to take like three
four years for something to like happen
and maybe that cancels out some of the
ROI from the project yeah yeah exactly
um if it's going to take you let's say
eight months you know to make this tenth
of a percent increase is that worth it I
mean yeah and then other factors you
know like well maybe in a couple of
years we know things will change so
maybe that 10th perc isn't even going to
last us that long because things will
change in and then that so yeah I didn't
use tenth of a percent because it's like
a good Target I used tenth of a percent
just uh because I was writing this five
minutes ago um but you should have
obviously I think a lot of times the
benefit needs to just be unquestionably
worth the time investment you know like
it's yeah
it you know it often just doesn't come
up because it's just so obviously like
um the you know the the the reward to
investment ratio is should be high
enough that it's just not a hang up if
it's if it is getting that marginally
close like it's probably not something
to pursue because let's face it most
ideas Fall
flat yeah I guess I'm kind of like
really interested in this question
because we have a small data science
team and we get a lot of different we
have a lot of needs we have a lot of
requests and we have um we support the
whole app at JPL where you got a lot of
um a lot of different needs but we also
just have we very focused um areas so we
kind of have to like run things through
like well does this support the vision
you know like our vision statement here
does it support the strategy but also
yeah we have like 10 10 projects that
are great ideas but which of those
10 um would be the best Roi would have
the best R so it's it's all about like I
think for me competing priorities so um
with a limited amount of resources we
have um I have found it really helpful
like as I've gotten more into basy and
statistics um you know this idea of a
prior probability particularly around
success and
and you know I think this is I this this
to me maps exactly with your question
it's like you know you have multiple uh
potential projects you could pursue and
you know it's like you're probably like
you know you and your stakeholders are
like really the experts in this space at
the company like put a prior probability
of success around it like you know what
is the range of outcomes that you know
going into the project like you know it
might realize you know it might it might
manifest as and then uh I think that
could be enormously helpful in helping
you decide is this something we should
like Explore More or is this something
that's like promising enough that like
it's time to like go do it um but again
like you know I I think prior
to my like uh getting into basian
statistics that idea would not have been
as clear to me that like oh I could
actually like go into a project and I
always do in fact go into projects with
a prior estimate of like how successful
it's likely to be what the range of
effect size is I I might reasonably
expect are I just wasn't making it
explicit before I learned basian
statistics but it's hugely important
like you know if you if everything you
do has a low prior probability of
success you're just generating noise um
so yeah helpful I appreciate that I'd
love to pull was someone just about to
ask a question I was I can't figure out
how to raise my hand today go ahead so
sorry about that
um have you you guys ever run into an
issue where you have to make a change
because maybe it's compliance or legal
and you still have to then estimate like
the amount of time it's going to take to
do that where like the return on
investment is not necessarily like the
there may be dollars saved to do this
but you also are legally required to to
make those changes and so then you have
to kind of like plan out your project
from that
perspective um I know working with hosp
hosital there's a lot of compliance
regulations and so curious how you guys
approach those kinds of um those kinds
of requests if we have to make a change
within one of our own projects that we
just we make the change uh there's no no
discussion really about how long is this
going to take or what is the what is the
return here because we've already got
the return or know what the return is or
has been from that project or that that
initiative um so in the case of
something where it's like compliance or
security or critical upgrade we're just
gonna do it like there's no question
about it we're just going to do
it yeah I've run into issues where um
you know we're trying to do something
because it's a potential compliance
thing and so you get into that hairy
thing where it's like okay well maybe
it's fine but maybe it's not fine and if
it's if they decide that it's not fine
then it's a problem but that like living
in that fuzzy area where we' like to
invest something earlier than like
before it's a huge problem like becomes
a weird thing because saying like well
this could be an all Oro situation if we
are
non-compliant is not really something
that I've had a lot of success bringing
up to kind of prioritizing those
projects if it so I want to make sure I
understand your question so obviously
anything that's like a question of legal
compliance it's just like yeah go to do
it you like um well sometimes we get um
we get documentation from government
part Partners or Regulatory Agencies
that's like hey these are proposed
changes we don't know if we're going to
lock these in yet but it could happen
like we could decide when we release the
final version of this to do this and so
you have like a six-month window where
you've got to like size up what what
that difference is okay okay so if I
understand this better now um I'm sorry
if my answer sound a pedantic before I
was I was like you know I was was hoping
it would lead into something more but um
so if if there's this potential thing
that could happen is what you're saying
yeah that could impact you okay so again
I find this basian idea of an expected
loss really helpful okay and this is
when yeah you don't know like the future
is uncertain you know like you don't
know what's going to happen but there's
some probability it's going to happen
and there's a range of uh penalties or
losses you could incur if it does happen
and like a real simple example is that
like if there's a 10% chance you're
going to lose a dollar your expected
loss is 10% of a dollar you know 10
pennies um versus a 90% chance you're
going to lose a dollar that's a 90 Cent
expected loss and so you can I think
like given that uncertainty it's not a
question of like breaking the law but
like you know your question is around
like oh we don't know if there's gonna
be these regulations in the future how
much might this impact us I think this
expected loss framework can really help
um like support rational decision-
making in in in an uncertain future
rather than always jumping to the most
extreme worst case scenario which is not
an optimal way to to make
decisions um
yeah I want to Echo what um somebody
said in the chat and it's a phone number
so I don't know who it is but um it it
does seem like we're discussing
different they said and equally
important methods of establishing Roi
and I'm realizing that as well that I
think in my head I always thought of
like Roi is like you have to come up
with this like accounting number like
the the
actual number that this going to impact
in terms of like Revenue versus thinking
of the like statistical side of things
as well so it's really interesting there
was a good question in the chat Rachel
about like how to handle when your
project underperforms
relative have JD um ask that one live JD
if you wna jump in here
yeah sorry if my treadmill is a little
loud I don't have my headphones in right
now no we can't we can't hear it we
can't hear it and shout out to the cats
who code t-shirt
yeah um yeah I guess I was just
wondering like how you handle if a
project that you had to pitch and sort
of fight for um how you handle if maybe
it underd delivers or underperforms you
said um mostly I guess I'm wondering
about like the trust aspect of um like
the decision makers or
stakeholders um how that impacts any
future proposals you have for projects
so you got to remember a like there's
variability in the world and B you can't
control everything and the thing you can
control though is
transparency um and so I think it's like
just really key that
like one you know your findings so your
Roi projections should reflect a
range to begin with you know I mean even
just like mean and interval is like a
great Anchor Point of like just to
remind them like we don't know the
future with certainty like this is the
like reasonable range of outcomes we
might expect um and then like just to
you know be transparent throughout about
how you without drowning them in detail
but just be transparent about like how
you arrived at your numbers and then
like what you know you saw at end of
season I mean there have certainly been
projects even success uccessful projects
that have been on that along the way
fell short you know because we uh we
were unaware of some key factor um you
know and then you you learn because it
doesn't deliver the way that you
expected it to and uh never during that
did I feel like the leaders who had
invested in us were upset or frustrated
it was like look we we leaned into a
difficult problem and we learned along
the way and and these are you know clear
about like this was what we overlooked
this is the correction we put in place
as we pursue it next time um and I think
that that's that transparency and
honesty is like the most you can do but
again just also anchor them to a just
get them thinking ahead of time about
like there's a range of outcomes we
could experience even if we did
introduce this true Improvement of you
know 1% or 2% like it's sampling
variation it's it it could show up in in
our you know customer sample for the
year as a lot of different values that's
not how normal people think normal
people think very like causally
narratively precisely um they don't
think in terms of variance so you have
to kind of condition your uh key
stakeholders uh to that to expect that
kind of variance and they'll they all
appreciate it in my
experience I want to remind everybody if
you do want to um provide some
perspective here too and and weigh in on
what you're doing feel free to raise
your hand just so I know to call on you
it's in the zoom bar below if you click
on reaction you'll have a a raised hand
sorry Derek no worries it's okay um so
to the underd delivered part we this is
probably gonna be very different uh to
what Joe said too uh but like we we have
maybe like four different ways in which
we can expect Andor watch uh act
potential or actual under delivered uh
projects so early in our Baseline like
trying to EST Lish um what the effects
really might be if it looks like it's
not quite as big of say an issue or
feasible uh for us to pursue it and we
suspect it would be something that
underd delivers on the potential impact
we're not going to do it uh during model
building if we do not cross certain
acceptable thresholds uh in particular
things around like Precision recall or
pbv and MPV like we have some
deployments like do not miss like you
just absolutely do not miss prediction
um um if the models aren't performing
well enough like we will not go forward
with it um which seems probably pretty
typical but then we get into um a little
bit later
where say in kind of like an earlier
silent deployment um we can watch things
for a while be very cautious and safe
for some of our stuff uh but then and I
think Chloe's here so she can definitely
jump in and talk a lot about this um uh
for some of the work we do um and sorry
if this kind of gets a little maybe ml
opsy but we have like two types of
monitoring we do uh one is we monitor
models and we monitor the intervention
so the model May Target one thing while
it's use is meant to impact something
else and those are the primary metrics
that we that I showed um if we're not
seeing say an actual impact uh or
something is going in the wrong
direction like that for us is is underd
deliver and you just stop um so we are
also carefully watching the intended
intervention um metrics here which is
the primary metrics of like what you're
going to change in the hospital and um
fortunately we don't really have
anything that underd delivers because we
do like Joe said we understand
variability like things are very weird
especially just a smidgen outside or
still within the pandemic in healthcare
like things are all over the place um
but uh we've been talking a lot about
this in the context of um one of our
particular projects
where um in the inter or in the post
phase it's been deployed it's being used
made a big impact dropped readmission
rates and we're seeing over time it's
drifting back up so we have this really
really uncomfortable question right now
what if we pull it does everything just
jump back up or is this a natural Trend
back up where something about the
deployment a year later is not quite
actually working um
so yeah we have to start thinking about
this we didn't really underd deliver but
we're starting to lose some ground and
we don't know if it's actually like what
we did or if it's something bigger which
is probably the case within an exhausted
Health Care System where like
readmission rates are just kind of up in
general so this is actually super tricky
for us because we're we're at a point
where we need to figure
out as the direction of an intervention
is kind of losing some ground um what do
we do
um I'm thinking also as we talk about
this that like you know we mentioned
earlier like you know there's metrics
your stakeholders all like align on and
value um I'm thinking also about like
just ex explicitly redefining those
metrics in some cases is often really
valuable and this goes to that like
underperformance issue is um that two
people can mean completely different
things by the same metric and if you've
both explicitly defined it and then
thought ahead about like what are
potential ways where like I like Derek's
monitoring question or monitoring answer
a lot like what are things what are ways
things can go arai and how can you get
ahead of that um so like you know you
think about AB testing or
experimentation in science like science
really cares about false positives like
they don't want false positive effects
getting into that like body of you know
of scientific
knowledge I think that's a lot less
important in industry it's matters in
medicine so I'm gonna I'll say to Derek
skates like this is not his approach but
but if you think about like in Tech a
lot of times a false positive is a free
mistake like all the development costs
are sunk by the time that the test runs
if you release you know some minor
change that turns out to be like a false
positive result um no one's harmed by
this it's actually the false negatives
in Tech that are really dangerous and
those are not the priority in
statistical significance testing in
other areas the reason I'm bringing all
this up is like so I work on
experimentation like things that I get
metrics that matter to me and my
stakeholders are like accuracy and uh
duration or speed so like well what's
accuracy is accuracy avoiding false
positives they're free mistakes or can I
redefine accuracy as like some kind of
optimization rate that's focused more on
detecting true effects than avoiding
false effects like that kind of shift it
it accuracy is like a term we can all
throw around but like I've
you could completely redefine that and
justify justifiably but you need to get
your stakeholders on board that like hey
look we're not going to key your index
on like false positive rates you know
that's not what matters to us as a
business uh and again if you've
explicitly address that up front and you
say like look I think we could we could
have Better Business performance by
shifting our Focus for True positives
rather than avoiding these false
positives and then again you know you do
all your simulations to show why you've
got uh a promising way to pursue this
but you know you just admit up front
like we're going to have more false
positives and we're okay with that
because those are free mistakes in our
area those are not free mistakes in
medicine those are not free mistakes in
a lot of other areas but in many areas
of tech they are so um yeah just kind of
thinking in advance about like what are
ways that things could go arai or get
misinterpreted and then making sure that
you're you have the the tracking system
in place which is also just all going to
come key at the end of the project when
you have to
show uh like how did things you know
material realiz in real
life yeah definitely and uh Dan I see
you have something to add to this topic
too you want to jump in yeah although I
might be changing the subject a little
bit so I don't want to change if if
that's not what you want to
do oh that's okay but does anybody else
feel like this conversation could go on
for three hours about I feel like
there's so much to talk about
here yeah no sorry I'm battling a cold
too
um I feel like I'm the only nonata
scientist on the phone so the
conversation about uh Basi and
statistics is a little bit oh good
thanks Rachel make me feel good here um
you know the things that I'm thinking
about are maybe a little bit more
fundamental I think what Derek and Joe
are talking about are like really high
level I mean this is like professional I
know Joe you said you'd never been
taught this but I feel like you could
teach the class on it um the things that
I think about how to learn something in
just 10 years yeah just
exactly I what I think about this is you
know what does the company
need you know and I think Derek's
example that he showed was just so
perfect of this because it go it like it
didn't do it on purpose or it did it on
purpose but it wasn't like in your face
but it was like these are the metrics
the company actually cares
about how is what you're doing fixing
those metrics because I think what we
get a lot what what I tend to see is
passionate data scientists and they're
going off and they see stuff and they're
like oh I bet I could do this but it
doesn't come from this direct line from
strategy so I love
Derek's presentation of it because it's
like tell me where it is here so I think
that is if we had to take one thing away
from it I would love to take that away
yeah no I I 100% agree put it in the
metrics that your non-technical
stakeholders care about um yeah which is
probably not area under the curve you
you know it's like Liv saved beds empty
beds Etc yeah like just put it in those
terms and and the data scientist will be
compelled too you know so just go for
that lowest common denominator for
persuasion and then my next point then
I'll I'll get off my soap box here my my
next point was why are they asking about
Roi and you
know sometimes they ask about Roi
because it's a multi-billion dollar
decision right and so the CFO needs to
know right and so there 100% you need to
go dig into this but I think sometimes
they ask about Roi because they don't
think it's valuable and they're like
just asking you prove your value on this
and then I think you know sometimes
they're project that are devoid of any
kind of corporate metrics or anything
like that and so they're saying what's
the value so you could do all the work
you want you're never going to convince
them okay so you gotta you got to pull
it back to strategy somehow and that and
bring that
forward I guess I don't see those as
comp I don't see those as competing like
if you have a strategy a good strategy
should be anchored to like a clear goal
and then the company their leaders are
aligning resources to ensure the you
know successful pursuit of that goal I I
I I guess I I don't see I don't see the
conflict at all you know um no no no
those AR the conflict is is if
you're it it sound like your your
organizations are like very structured
and I think maybe some of the sciency
organiz it's a little bit looser and so
you get a little bit
more exploration and that that's not
very easy to tie back directly to
strategy by this is this is this is a
good point this is a good point some
things are like like I can think around
like skill development among the data
scientists and analysts like it's
something where it's like intuitively
it's like yeah if we invest in this like
this should pay dividends that will be
very very hard hard to measure but it's
like or you know the best measurement
you're going to get is probably
anecdotes and case studies
but is it still worth doing yes but like
again you're gonna have to be
transparent upfront that it's like we're
not going to be able to measure this
with like you know x% increased
conversions or decreased mortalities but
it's like where do the moonshot ideas
come from you know like uh again it kind
of depends on like you have to know your
leadership and like what do they have
appetite for like if you have if they
have some like Visionary bandwidth where
they're willing to float some of those
like moonshot like educations of
moonshot idea but you know like if
they're willing to like entertain some
of those less clear Investments good I
think that could be you could frame it
as part of a good Investment Portfolio
um but yeah it's you can't measure you
can't you can't measure those things
nearly as easily so exactly I think my
point was just to say that the people
trying to do those moonshots might get a
lot of questions about Roi might do as
much work as they can and still never
make it
so when you get those questions I think
it's just worth thinking why are they
asking me this you know where where's
how do we position this is it possible
to convince them okay something I
thought would might be helpful to add
too is is sometimes they're not asking
for the ROI like you might be sharing
what you think the potential Roi is to
help push your own idea forward and that
they're not necessarily asking you like
what's the specific Roi of this and
that's something that I've been thinking
about a lot lately like when I have an
idea for something and I want to go run
to share it with our leadership team
like putting together the business case
for that and explaining like this is why
I think this is a good idea here's the
examples where this has come up or um
and I know one other nonata scientist
that I saw was listening in is our
president here at posit and he's often
one of the people that I go to with some
of the these ideas so tar I was
wondering if you had anything you wanted
to add to the conversation too it's
interesting I mean I think both Joe uh
uh and and raay really important uh
points here I I like to sort of ask
myself the question like what is the
what are the underlying assumptions
behind anything that we're doing right
like whether it's on the strategy level
like what is the what is the end goal
here and then how do I know that I'm on
the right path um uh that being said you
also want to leave enough space for the
moonshots but I challenge everybody when
they say hey I want to do X I'm like why
and and what are the metrics that you
are hoping to drive it's interesting
when you show the in form I was that's
it's intriguing because that is an
existing system that you have the
question that I found myself asking is
like okay how long does it take before
you know that you've got a good uh test
and uh and when does the impact sort of
kick in right because some things like
in product development for us when we're
building new features or new products or
whatnot it could take 18 months 24
months before you know whether that
investment was a good investment or not
but uh but I I think it's good
discipline in general to sort of say hey
you know what here's what I'm assuming
is going to change uh or here's what I'm
assuming is going to get better here's
how I'm going to measure it uh and then
and then use that as a way to learn and
get better right that's sort of my my
instinct on it the moonshot one is a
good is a good question like I think I
think you might want to be okay with
saying hey 5 to 10% of all the
Investments that I make are going to be
these kinds of moon shots and I'm okay
if they fall flat on their face uh JJ
and I do that uh pretty regularly when
we say hey you know what like this is
you know we're going to take a crack at
X or Y or Z and and we'll make an
investment that we're like if it fails
it's not going to kill the company but
if if it succeeds could could it'll
generate a lot of a lot more Revenue so
that I don't know if that's what you
were looking for for me Rachel but I
push Rachel pretty hard when she's like
I've got seven ideas I'm like great
which one
matters um there was a comment earlier
about like you know your personal time
investment and this kind of like echoed
me was I so I used to build furniture
that was like before I was in tech and
estimating how long a new piece of
furniture was going to take was really
hard and so when I took really good
notes what I learned was this that if I
had if I built something similar before
I had to triple my estimate and if I
hadn't built anything similar before I
had to multiply times nine and people
friends would say like oh you're
terrible at doing estimates and I'd be
like no I'm awesome at doing estimates
um and then when I got to grad school I
found that the mechanical engineers had
names for this they called it the rule
of Pi that everything takes 3.14 times
longer than you uh remember it taking
and and so I the point of all this was
just like as you think about like your
own time investment like you know as you
you've done all the Roa but like just
making sure you have bandwidth to see
this through successfully if you've done
something really similar before triple
it if you've never done something
similar before like multiply times nine
and I can tell you on my own projects
usually like just that ninefold thing is
just like all the stuff you didn't think
of like okay you put the model into
production well now you need to like
train every relevant user uh you need to
like build enormous amount of documents
enormous amount of tracking this is all
the stuff that was not part of the model
development and if you don't have time
for it well your life's going to be
really miserable for the rest of the
year while you know you're working
nights and weekends to see it through or
just budget really over budget for time
and you know you can have a happy life
and um you know get things going I I I
just want to add one more thing to what
you just said Joe I love this I'm not
going to think about this piie squared
idea but the the the other thing that I
think think is really important is to
just remember that the more things you
take on simultaneously the more your
work in progress increases the more your
context switching and things will
actually take longer than you even
realize like so so I know this is kind
of like meat and potatoes for a lot of
people but it's so easy to get you know
sucked in and say oh this is not going
to take long I'll do this I'll do this
you know before you know it you're doing
17 things at the same time and that just
slows The Living Daylights out of out of
you you know um this hour goes by very
quickly here um but I know if people
have to run at the top of the hour
that's okay thank you for joining us but
I'm going to stay on and hang out if
people want to keep talking too but um
Brian I saw you had your hand raised too
if you want to jump
in yeah so I mean I come at this so
early on my career I was actually in
charge of doing projects like this and
actually presenting them as budget items
for the Coast Guard to Congress and you
get your ass
grilled um and so like for instance when
I ran a data science team at an
insurance company all of our projects
were
Roi the goal of this project is to shave
x% off this cost it's worth X here are
all the variables these are what we
think the ranges are this is a project
we should do um and the way we engage
our team to Tes Point yes when you
multitask you're really in trouble um we
always had a every every team member had
a short project the quick and easy the
medium project and a long project
because in a long project which means
there is going to be time for
stakeholders to make decisions and do
stuff and they don't turn around on a
dime so you have a midpoint and you do a
presentation you're not going to hear
anything for feedback two or three weeks
that's when you can work on other stuff
um on a financial basis we I always just
to do stuff is what we call real options
your first is your exploratory POC
what's that going to cost what's the
benefit benefits probably close to zero
but it's going to be an investment cost
but then you have an option to kill an
option to expand or an option to do
something else and if you can think
about some of those options you can
price them out and so I had to present
all my projects five years here's the
return here's the discounted value
here's the return because our I had to
go through this um CIO who went to the
CFO and that's how they looked at things
you know I want to
buy hit connect and it's cost me x
amount of bucks a year for a license
these are the benefits I'm going to get
from it these are the amount of people
that I'm going to have it's going to
cost me x amount of person all these
things and so I have these presentations
to
people and you could go through those
discussions and um we would do variable
sensitivity goes back to that never
present a point estimate you know this
it's a range between this and that it's
a range between this and that it's a
range between X and Y and if you get
really fancy you can actually convolve
them all in a simulation say here is the
entire range of outcomes and this is
what it looks like no it's not a belt
curb it never is um but so I mean when
you when you talk about R that's how
I've always thought about that's how
I've always been forced to present it
though because if I'm
asking my division leader president
whoever to spend 50 75 or 100 Grand or
to
dedicate you know you think about a man
a person hours 2,000 hours in a year
maybe I want to dedicate a th000 hours
of a data scientist that cost me x
amount of money what am I going to get
for that um and that's just some of the
ways that I've had to present it and
Pitch it and you know get people to sign
off and say yes we will give you the
money or we will give you the time to do
that um and to the earlier point it's
all about what metrics what are you
going to improve you're either going to
improve revenue or cut costs or improve
efficiency would cut
cost you have to have that in mind
otherwise you know it's just R&D and and
if it's just R&D then then you got to be
able to pitch that to hey this is R&D we
don't have anything for it but we're
going in a space that we've never been
before and sometimes that's just you got
to be honest with that yeah well maybe
while we're on the insurance example
here jump over to Adam's question in the
chat if you if you're still on Adam oh
yeah could be a real Rabbit Hole uh so
we're almost at time I don't want to
keep anybody but yeah I think the
question is you know we talking earlier
about um this like idea like false
positives and true positives and you can
kind of like in a classification problem
you can kind of like tune that you kind
of associate costs and things to those
various outcomes
um yeah so in insurance I'm in Property
and Casualty Insurance and we work on uh
models that go into pricing and it's way
more complicated than just sort of like
true and false positives we sort of
build a pricing model we we try to
estimate losses for a given set of
features and and then what happens is
that that all that information kind of
goes over the wall to actal Partners our
our product Partners who have certain
kinds of business objectives they have
to hit so actually the models kind of
get like tweaked and and and modified
and then they layer in additional things
like discounts and so forth and so when
I go in thinking about okay I want to
improve these models maybe I'm bringing
in a new thirdparty data source for
example I want to figure out if this is
a worthwhile data source to include
um I have to figure out is the model
improving but then I have to know also
is it worth buying right um and so the
models kind of decoupled in some ways
from the final outcomes in really
complex ways and I'm wondering if
there's some way to think about this
fuzzy sort of connection between model
Improvement and Roi at the end of the
day it's a long-winded explanation but
no no I I think a lot of decisions get
made on overly simple metrics just
because it's so overwhelming like
like not all customers produce the same
amount of value but so many business
decisions are based exclusively on
conversion and retention as though every
customer were equally
valuable so but you're going to
overwhelm your stakeholders if you're
simultaneously like introducing like a
new justification for like oh well you
know deduct these costs add these like
lifetime value benefits Etc exactly
those have to become separate issues so
then you just have this like reliable
lifetime value metric you could pull off
the shelf and you could ask now hey what
if we made decisions based on three-year
uh Revenue per customer rather than raw
conversion which treats everyone as
equally
valuable uh you know how much more money
would we save how much more money would
we make um those are all kind of your
ways to shape Roi by redefining the
question I don't know maybe that was
kind of a theme today was actually just
like you are in a very powerful position
to redefine the question when you're
doing an Roi invest Roi inves vation and
don't take that lightly um but keep in
mind that people only have so much
attention so like you got to modularize
things so that they can stay on board I
see so many data science projects just
completely overwhelm uh you know their
their stakeholders so avoid that and you
know yeah you can you can get a lot of
influence from that so Gerard I I know
you had your hand raised so I know we're
right at time here but just wanted to
see if you had time to ask your question
oh I I just wanted to make a a comment
about these moonshot ideas and these
these R&D um ideas um we usually at the
beginning of the year just agree upon an
amount of time that you have to do
research and or uh for projects that
don't necessarily have an immediate
impact and then basically throughout the
year if you come across a new really
cool thing that you want to work
on the question immediately bounces back
to you is this worth stopping the other
research that you're doing right now and
switch through the new project can you
wrap it up can you switch because you
only have so much time and then there is
not even a need to
generate um a return on that investment
and
then usually I can myself answer the
question whether I want to switch or not
because I either you know don't want to
give up on the project that I'm working
on or uh I'm done with with the previous
project um I hope that helps
them well I don't want to keep you Derek
and Joe too long so thank you so much
for for sharing your your insights and
experience here I just want to see if
you had anything else you wanted to add
to the conversation before we
go it's hard yeah luck just give it just
give it 10 years and it'll be uh you
know no-brainer no this is great great
uh participation thanks everybody um was
good yeah this was this was awesome I
would love to keep having these
conversations um and I I mean I will
definitely stick around here but
understand people have to go to other
meetings and can only spend so much time
with us but um is this something we'd
like to kind of keep talking about or if
there are other specific topics we want
to do a deep dive on um please let me
know whether it's in the chat or if you
have an idea later you can message me on
LinkedIn or or email me just put my
email in here
too awesome thank you all so
much than thank
you I know there were a few great
questions that we didn't get to cover so
maybe I'll go and kind of collect one of
those or some of those um but Derek if
you are able to stay on I I saw one of
the questions was about um like the
infrastructure cost I believe I think
David Sloter asked this maybe how does
production resource cost like cloud
computing factor into your Roi
calculation here's an easy answer on the
cloud computing uh given that we're in a
hospital and in Canada with very
particular regulations we don't use the
cloud so so uh the infrastructure stuff
becomes part of like operational budgets
that we talk about in the beginning of
the year with everyone else including it
and other folks of like yeah if you want
these projects to keep going like this
is where you get to Point to your
previous Roi do you want projects that
will continue to bring down costs and
bring down readmissions and increase
patient flow this is the infrastructure
we need these are the subscriptions we
need um fortunately or unfortunately
we're entirely on Prem so I don't need
to talk about
Cloud for anybody who decided to hang
around here do you have any other last
pressing
questions um Jose or apologies for
mispronouncing your name I I saw you
shared um a framework in the chat and I
was wondering if you'd be open to
sharing a little bit about
that and no worries if I'm putting
anybody on the spot I'll try and go
through the the chat and pull out some
of those resources
there awesome well thank you all so much
for joining today this was a really fun
Lively conversation I really appreciate
it thanks again have a great rest of day
everybody let see see you later bye
bye